so last week I'm having dinner at this
restaurant and I'm looking around the
place is packed everyone's getting their
orders on time and I couldn't help but
think about the logistics that go into a
restaurant Turning raw ingredients into
these delicious meals so let's think
about this for a minute
so in a commercial kitchen
we have raw ingredients being delivered
by trucks
to our
loading dock on large pallets right so
truck comes in to the loading dock
they drop off the pallet and the truck
is back out on the road to deliver more
ingredients to other restaurants
so that's the easy part now we actually
have to unwrap this palette and process
it right we have to sort everything on
it we have to label all of our
ingredients
right and then we also have to make sure
that each item is routed to the correct
storage area so these things could be
going into
a pantry for dry goods or it could also
be going into large walk-in fridges and
freezers for things like fresh
vegetables and meats and we also have to
organize those storage areas right so
we've got to make sure that ingredients
that are expiring first are used first
we've got to make sure certain
ingredients are separated from one
another for contamination reasons and we
also have to make sure that certain
ingredients hit a very certain
temperature also for food safety
and by the way we need to do all of this
as quickly
as possible
right to minimize things like
food waste
to minimize
spoilage
that we could see from the ingredients
just sitting on the truck or on a pallet
right and without this process the cooks
in the kitchen
can't really do their job as effectively
or safely
they'd be spending a lot of their time
just looking for ingredients and less
time actually cooking and serving out
meals to their customers right
okay so what does this have to do with
data well if we think about it this very
same process also exists within data
architectures of
organizations
so you've got all sorts of different
data coming into your organizations from
different sources such as in different
Cloud environments
different operational applications now
we even have
social media data right
all this is coming into our organization
just like a kitchen has ingredients
coming from different suppliers
okay so constantly have data coming in
we need a quick place to dump all
different types of data in different
formats for later use so we have
data Lakes
now these Lakes allow us to cheaply and
quickly capture raw structured
and
unstructured and even semi-structured
data
okay so now just like in the kitchen
we're not really cooking on the loading
dock right now maybe I can put a tiny
Grill there if I really wanted to but we
have to organize and transform this data
from its raw State into something that's
usable for the kind of insights and
analytics that our business wants to
generate so we have
Enterprise data warehouses
or edws
right where data is loaded in sometimes
from a data Lake but sometimes from
other sources like operational
applications and it's optimized and
organized to run very specific
analytical tasks
now this could be
powering different business intelligence
or bi workloads such as building
dashboards and reports or it could be
feeding into other
analytical tools
just like our pantries and freezers
data in the warehouse is cleaned
organized governed and should be trusted
for integrity
okay
so what are some of the challenges that
we see in this approach well as we said
data Lakes are really awesome to capture
tons of data in a cost-effective way
but we run into challenges with
data governance
and data quality
right and a lot of times these data
Lakes can become
data swamps
and this happens when there's a lot of
duplicate inaccurate or incomplete data
making it difficult to track and manage
assets
so if you think about it what happens
when that data becomes stale well it
loses its value in creating insights the
same way that ingredients go bad over
time in our restaurant if we don't use
them
so data lakes also have challenges with
query performance since they're not
built and optimized to handle the
complex analytical queries it can
sometimes be tough to get insights out
of lakes directly
okay so let's take a look at the data
warehouse now now these are really great
at query performance
they're exceptional
but they can come at a high cost right
just like those big freezers are can be
very costly to run we can't put
everything into a data warehouse now
they can be better optimized to maintain
data governance and quality
but they have limited support for
semi-structured and unstructured data
sources by the way the ones that are
growing the most that are coming into
our organization
and they can also sometimes be too slow
for certain types of applications that
require the freshest data because it
takes time to sort clean and load data
into the warehouse
okay so what do we do here well
developers took a step back and said hey
let's take the best of both data lakes
and data warehouses and combine them
into a new technology called
the data
lake house
so we get the flexibility
and we get the cost effectiveness
of a data Lake and we get
the performance
and structure
of a data warehouse
so we'll talk more specifically about
the architecture of a data lake house in
a future video but from a value point of
view the lake house lets us lets us
store data from the exploding number of
new sources in a low-cost way and then
leverages built-in data management and
governance layers to allow us to power
both business intelligence
and high performance machine learning
workloads quickly
okay
so there are plenty of ways that we can
start using a lake house we can
modernize our existing data Lakes we can
complement our data warehouses to
support some of these new types of AI
and machine learning driven workloads
but we'll we'll also talk about that in
the future video
so the next time you're at a restaurant
I hope you think about how the meal on
your plate got there and the steps the
ingredients took to go from the kitchen
to the meal on your plate
thank you if you like this video and
want to see more like it please like And
subscribe if you have questions please
drop them in the comments below